I don't think political discourse can
work toward freedom I think political
discourse always works like when the two
parties come together you have war and
you have these massive expansions in the
state when have the two parties come
together to decrease to increase
freedoms and decrease the power of
government that's not a thing
that gives you hope relating that's
something you said earlier about how the
the Waf guys that maybe they're more
clownish I think that you said than than
god-like it's like so if we just keep
pushing that's what I was thinking all
week you know I was watching some of the
Al Gore you saw Al Gore ranting and
raving like a lunatic I was like this is
not a guy who's confident in his ideas
this is not a guy who's got a lot this
is like I mean he struck me as like Alex
Jones to Jason I don't even mean not to
put down Alex Jones I mean like the
level of like screaming in theater I was
like something doesn't seem right here
you you don't have to act like that if
you're running the table Yeah if you go
to Vegas right and the dealer who's
gonna win yeah odds in his favor you
don't see the blackjack dealer yeah yeah
the guy who's turning over the tables
the one playing Blackjack the one who's
in the losing position
um so I think that we are in a very
hopeful time I think the number of
Americans who are aware of uh the gun
controls are the other great example
yeah 20 years ago you'd have the gun
control people and then the gun rights
people and they'd be arguing and at a
certain point and I don't know what the
turning point was the gun rights people
were like we're not even having this
argument because you're not already in
good faith you say you don't want to
take our guns we know you do we
understand why it's a non-starter you
every time there's a tragedy which is
absolute a tragedy which we would love
to be able to prevent you use as an
excuse to take my weaponry and my
ability to protect my family from the
best from the bad guys it's like there's
not a conversation to be had so I think
that kind of understanding I think and
it comes from both sides I think uh from
Blue States they just think these Maga
people completely out to lunch mindless
they're an occult they love Trump
there's nothing there's nothing to talk
to them about that to me is is healthy I
don't think political discourse can work
toward freedom I think political
discourse always works like when the two
parties come together you have war and
you have these massive expansions in the
state when have the two parties come
together to decrease to increase
freedoms and decrease the power of
government that's not a thing maybe
after World War II yeah yeah maybe
they've come together every now and
they're going to bomb the hell out of
somebody it makes us feel good for a few
days right right usually but not them
and those people grow up right
um so all right so let's bring it back
to the book for a second so the book
basically is about the fall of the
Soviet and the rise yeah and that yeah
and then afterwards the white pill is is
afterwards and now but there's a lot of
weird stuff going on in that part of the
world right now well that's true so one
of the points I make is people have this
you know I'm an anarchist as you know
and people both say anarchism utopian
and then condemn it for not providing
one Utopia is not possible but wins are
progress art I mean the sense progresses
I mean moving in the right direction and
we see them all the time and constantly
in just one example is the fact that
they folded on those vaccine passwords I
don't think that's a net win I mean it's
a net loss it moved in the wrong
direction but the point is guns is
another example the fact that if you
look at Wikipedia uh the amount it used
to be almost impossible to get like a a
shall issue uh you know in different
states and now it's it's become part of
the constitution in many different
states uh the fact that you have all
these states brazenly defying Washington
drug legalizations is another one
whether you like it or not the fact that
you have state States who are willing to
you know have markets that are in
defines the federal law that is a step
in the right direction so and I think
the
for a long time and this kind of Harkens
back to like the Rush Limbaugh era there
was this idea that's Republicans versus
Democrats and now I think if I talk to
most people and they say who do you
think is more of a pernicious influence
on American culture 50 Democratic
senators or 50
Executives in New York Times they're all
going to say the New York Times and
they're going to be right so the fact
that you're identifying where this
toxicity and malevolence is coming from
uh you're you're shooting at the wrong
people and I'm saying that figuratively
please
yes we will make note of that yes
literally
um but it is weird right because you'd
think that more people at this point
well you're saying basically that enough
people recognize it and yet these things
never change their tactics right so I
always say it's like you guys the New
York Times mainstream media CNN it's
like you guys don't have to be good you
really don't but just don't be patently
horrible but they seem incapable of even
doing it that's the thing they're first
there there's an accusation that
conservatives have Echo Chambers there's
some truth to that but the amount of
echo chamberism on you know the people
who are the New York Times is just
through the roof right uh there's no
perception that anyone who is in the out
group can have any even not only just a
good idea but just simply valid
criticism look what they did to Elon
Musk they loved Elon Musk yeah right
yeah right he's saving the planet and
now he you know he's he's uh basically
Trump Jr somehow
um so there is this kind of increasing
siloization of American culture but
that's really bad because if I'm in
power and I want to maintain my power
and I see that there's this big part of
the population that is a threat to my
power even my power is illegitimate and
malevolent I still got to know who's
coming at me what are the metrics so on
and so forth and they're just talking in
circles and I remember in 2016 after
Trump won and this was a huge like wake
up moment for many people uh the the
head of times I think Dean banquet was
just saying like Okay we gotta do better
like we missed the Mark here and that
kind of went out the window very very
quickly completely went out the window
give me the white pill on on the tech
situation because we okay so we are here
and again you're you're on locals
malice.locals.com I'm a professional uh
there are things being built Rumble is
building things there are Bitcoin I know
crypto is hurting right now but like
there are decentralization things hold
on crypto's not hard and crypto's cheap
right so crypto is cheap so it's
probably good but I meant herding in the
sort of like broad sense of it's not you
know bitcoin's not at 70 grand which is
sure a year ago
um but on the tech side it still does
feel like we got all this information
that the government literally is
colluding with big Tech to silence us
like quite literally there's evidence of
it it's all out there I don't think
these NPCs blew blue people I don't
think they care they don't care their
minds I think they're yeah but I mean I
don't think they're relevant like if so
this is an argument I have a lot with
people who are for democracy and I I
can't seem to get through them and it's
just very frustrating when you go to a
farm right the farmer's always going to
be out who would you rather have on your
side the farmer or the 100 cows then
it's not a numbers game you're making it
a numbers game because you've been
taught since you're a kid that the
numbers determine what happens but
that's completely false and one obvious
example was Obamacare the Democrats had
super majorities and so they had the
numbers in terms of politicians yeah but
the population was like 70 30 against
the 60s 40 against it they put it
through anyway so politicians use
democracy and the masses as a mechanism
to validate that which they wanted to do
anyway but if the populist support isn't
there they're still going to push ahead
they don't care that all they care about
is their power and their agenda so yes
there's a big percentage of population
who are functionally Mindless and I
don't think this is exclusive to Blue
States or blue people at all blue voters
at all but to me they're just largely
irrelevant I think what matters is are
you going to attract the quality minds
are you going to attract the people who
are innovators who are moving culture
forward I I if Elon Musk voted Democrat
Democrat Party Line but he was doing
what not taibi is not a right-winger
Glenn Greenwald is a hardcore Lefty yeah
so Jimmy Dore is another one I know if
there's beef with you and him but
whatever no no we said we settled it out
okay good that's not even publicly we
did probably I've never said it on air
before I just had my show is it great I
don't agree with him on a lot but I mean
when you have people who are honest and
have a left-wing perspective that's fine
yeah and and who are a threat to those
in power that's you know there's so much
talk about how journalism is speaking to
power and one of the things this drives
me crazy because conservatives always
say oh when I was a kid journalists are
honest no when you were a kid you were a
kid when you were a kid you think no one
has sex no one does drugs no one drinks
because you don't see it because you're
a kid so you're going to be oblivious to
all these lies and machinations and um
misdirection but one of the things to
talk about in the book is they've been
at this for over a century and have the
receipts when the New York Times
literally New York Times was covering up
the starvation of the ukrainians and the
haldemore there's a great book called
buried by the times which talks about
how they obscured Hitler's assaults on
the Jews because they'll be validating
his view that Jews are separate race so
these we all I keep making this point
constantly and I hope people understand
it we all learned in high school about
yellow journalism right and how they led
us into the Spanish-American War during
William McKinley and there's a record
scratch and the journalists are honest
and then like 20 years ago they became
dishonest it's the same people it's the
same thing for over a century yeah I'm
glad you said that because I think it's
I think people think about it a lot
somehow that the NBC Nightly News and
the ABC news that it was all even keeled
and whatever but it was like it couldn't
have been it just couldn't have been by
every estimation of what we know about
how humans operate and I'm sorry to all
the Boomers listening to this but Walter
Cronkite was a lot closer to Brian
stelter than he is to you if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell